the three phases we all go through with
parents and kids right you first face
you know kids idolize their parents
then second phase they demonize their
parents oh i saw what you did that you
know your mom i said they demonize then
third phase is they humanize their
parents right i'm assuming an agent a
cia agent or an fbi in nsa probably goes
through those three phases with the
agency as well
you first idolize like two others you're
like oh my god
andy cia that's sick that for oh my i'd
be using that to get laid every day you
know that's what i'd be doing right so
i'm assuming like phase one is dude i'm
idolizing i'm part of the freaking cia
and second phase like damn that's some
dirty stuff right there because there's
stuff you know that we don't know right
so then you demonize
then you humanize and you say well these
are not perfect people everybody makes
mistakes and every organization makes
mistake corporations make mistakes
governmental agencies make mistakes etc
etc so you go more in the humanizing
phase but while somebody's in the
demonizing phase
and they're seeing the dark side of the
organization
that's that's a vulnerable area for
somebody to come in and exploit that
opportunity absolutely okay and many
have from the outside right many we've
had agents that have
been bought money sex women all of that
stuff
for me when it says a lifelong type of
in india you call it secrecy
you know i i don't know it's like
sometimes i wonder if it's happening we
don't know about it but they can't talk
about it because it'll ruin the
credibility of the existing agency
because how do some people know so much
about us
where they getting there until like you
were talking about how russia on another
podcast you were talking about how great
of a job russia has done
against ukraine how they're actually
getting exactly what they want yes you
know
ukraine has shown a lot of strength but
maybe russia's
strategy is working very effectively how
they're getting their intel i don't know
even you said you said i don't know how
they're getting
how they're doing what they're doing so
how are they doing it maybe
we have some people that are supporting
them could that be a possibility i would
say it's more than a possibility it's
almost a guarantee okay that we that the
united states in the world of
intelligence we all
assume
that we are penetrated to some level or
or another right penetrated means we
have a mole
among us or we have information leaks
among us there's a technical operation
collecting information from servers or
databases somewhere right you have to
assume
that you're compromised
because if you assume that you're not
compromised you're even more exposed to
risk
so assume that your compromised
compartment compartmentalize from there
and act appropriately increase your
security from there right just like i
joked about the guy who didn't let me in
the front door that's awesome security
for valuetainment this building is that
much more secure because that guy in in
the face of doubt kept me out
no problem he let me in eventually guys
getting a promotion by the way
but that's that's how you have to
operate if you want to maximize security
right when it comes to why we don't
speak out of school yeah we don't want
to dishonor our country we don't want to
dishonor cia we don't want to smear our
family names but we also for damn sure
don't want to give our enemies
information they might be able to use
against us just so that we can talk
about it on cnn or talk about it in the
press there's an awesome example of
osama bin laden from
from 2000 2002 2003 the washington uh
the wall street times or maybe the new
york times wall street journal in new
york times
was speaking to
a as a
intelligence service anonymous source
and they talked about how we were
tracking bin laden through his satellite
phone
that that was a source and a method
right the one thing we're not supposed
to talk about and then because of that
bin laden stopped using that satellite
phone completely changed his
communication strategy went dark went
black and we had to start all over again
damn i don't want to give
china
any advantages i don't want to give
russia any advantages i want to give the
american people every advantage we can
give them but i also want to be able to
talk honestly about what my peers don't
talk about because just like you're
saying i want to respect my secrecy
agreement but i also want to be able to
shed some additional perspective on the
awesome work that the men and women
still inside get to do
the privilege that i have as an american
being able to leave and still talk about
it because if i was in france i wouldn't
be able to if i was in china i wouldn't
be able to if you're a svr officer in
russia once you leave you don't get to
talk about it so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]